from a financial from a human
perspective with the volatility you
mentioned you could have gotten it for a
nickel and the risk was great where's
the risk today what's your sense you
know we're 13 years end to this entire
activity i think the risk has never been
lower i
i if you look at all the risks right the
risk the risks in the early years
are
is the engineering protocol proper like
one megabyte block size 10 minute clock
frequency cryptographies first will it
be hacked or will it crash
730 000 blocks and it hasn't crashed
will it be hacked hasn't been hacked but
you know it's a lindy thing right you
wait 13 years to see if it'll be hacked
but on the other hand
with a billion dollars it's not as
interesting a target as it is with 100
billion and when it gets to be worth a
trillion
then it's a bigger target so
so the risk has been bleeding off over
time as the network monetized
i think the second question is will it
be banned
you couldn't know it could it literally
could have been banned at any time many
times early on in fact in 2013 i tweeted
on that subject i thought it would be
banned
i i made a very fame infamous famous
tweet i thought it was it was going to
be banned
in 2014 the irs um designated it as
property and gave it property tax
treatment okay so
they they could have given it a tax
treatment where you had to pay tax on on
the unrealized capital gains
every year and it probably would have
crushed it to death
right you know so so it could have been
in any
in any number of places banned by a
government but in fact it was
legitimized as property
and then the question is would it be
hacked or would it be copied will it be
something better than that and it was
copied 15 000 times and you know the
story of all those and
and they either diverge to be something
totally different and not comparable or
someone trying to copy a non-sovereign
bearer instrument store of value found
that the their network's crashed to be
one percent of what bitcoin is so
now we're sitting
at a point where all those risks are out
of the out of the way i would say that
year one of institutional adoption
is uh it started august
2020 that's when microstrategy bought
250 million dollars worth of bitcoin and
we put that on the wire we were the
first publicly traded company to
actually buy
uh
bitcoin i don't think you could have
found a five million dollar purchase
from a public company before we did that
so that was kind of like a gun going off
and then in the next 12 months
tesla bought bitcoin square bought
bitcoin and i'd say now we're in year
two of institutional adoption and uh
about 24 should be 24 publicly traded
bitcoin miners by the end of this
quarter
so you're looking at 36 publicly traded
companies
and you've got
50
at least in the range of 50 billion
dollars on the balance of bitcoin on the
balance sheet of publicly traded
companies and hundreds of billions of
dollars of market cap
of bitcoin exposed companies
so i i would say the asset
decade one was entrepreneurial
experimental
decade two is a rotation from
entrepreneurs institutions and is
becoming institutionalized so maybe
decade one you go from zero to a
trillion and a decade to you go from one
trillion to a hundred trillion what
about governments uh government adoption
institutional adoption
is our governments important in this
maybe making it
some governments
incorporating it into as a currency into
their
banks uh all that kind of stuff is that
important and if if it is when when will
it happen
it's not essential for the success of
the asset class but i think it's it's
inevitable in various degrees over time
but uh the most likely thing to happen
next is um
large uh acquisitions by institutional
investors
of bitcoin as a digital gold where
they're just swapping out gold for for
digital gold and thinking of it like
that
and the government entities most likely
to be involved with that would be
sovereign wealth funds
if you look at all the sovereign wealth
funds that are holding a big tech stock
equities the swiss the norwegians the
middle easterners
if you can hold big tech then holding
digital gold would be
you know not not far removed from that
that's a non-controversial
adoption
i think there are there are
opportunities for governments that are
much more profound right if a government
started to adopt
bitcoin as a treasury reserve asset
that's much bigger than just a
an asset investment that's 100 x bigger
and you could imagine that's like a
trillion dollar opportunity like any
government that wanted to adopt it as a
treasury reserve asset would probably
generate trillions of dollars
a trillion or more of value
and then you know the thing that people
think about is well will oil ever be
priced in bitcoin
or any other export commodity
i think there's like 1.8 trillion
dollars or more of export commodities
in the world and right now they're all
priced in dollars i i think that this is
a colorful thing but not really that
relevant like you could sell all that
stuff in dollars that that the relevant
decision that any institution makes
whether they're a non-profit a
university a corporation or a government
is what's your treasury reserve asset
and if your treasury reserve asset is
the peso and if the peso's
losing 20 or 30 of its value a year
then
you know your your balance sheet is
collapsing
within five years and if the treasury
reserve asset is uh is dollars and
currency derivatives and u.s treasuries
then you're getting your
seven right now it's probably 15
or more
monetary inflation we're running double
the historic average you could argue
triple somewhere between double and
triple depending upon
what your metric is
so you know do i think it'll happen i
think that they're conservative but they
have to be shocked and i think there is
a shock
the the late russian
sanctions are a big shock that when the
west sees 300 billion dollars worth of
russian gold and currency derivatives i
think
you know you got the famous quote by
putin that you know
we have to rethink our
our treasury strategies and that pushes
everybody toward a commodity strategy
what commodities do i want to hold
i think that's got a lot of people
thinking i think it's got the chinese
thinking everybody wants to be the
reserve currency right so if i buy 50
billion dollars worth of dollars every
year then
i buy 500 billion
over a decade
and i probably
pay
250 billion dollars of inflation cost on
the backs of my
citizens in a decade so
so inflation could be one of the sources
of shock
and you wonder if there is a switch to
bitcoin whether it would be a bang or a
whimper
like what is the nature of the shock of
the transition i think that
uh the year 2022 is pretty catalytic
for digital assets in general and for
for bitcoin in particular the canadian
trucker crisis
i think educated hundreds of millions of
people and and made them start
questioning their property rights and
their banks
i think the
ukraine war
was a second shock but i think that the
russian sanctions was a third shock
yeah i think all three of the and i i
think hyperinflation in the rest of the
world is a fourth shock and then
persistent inflation the us is a fifth
shock
so i think it's a perfect storm
and if you put all these events together
what do they signify they signify the
rational conclusion for any person
thinking about this is
i'm not sure if i can trust my property
i don't know if i have property rights i
don't know if i can trust the bank
and if i'm politically at odds with
with
the leader of my own country
i'm going to lose my property and
if i'm politically at odds with the
owner of another country
i'm still going to lose my property
and when push comes to shove the banks
will freeze my assets and seize them
and i think that uh that that is playing
out
in front of everybody in the world
such that
your logical
response would be
i'm going to convert my
weak currency to a strong currency
like i'll convert my peso and lyra to
the dollar
i'm going to convert my weak property to
strong property
i'm going to sell my building
downtown moscow and i'd rather own
a building in new york city i'd rather
i'd rather own in a powerful nation than
a
than be stuck with a building in nigeria
or a building in argentina or whatever
so so i'm going to sell my weak
properties by strong properties i'm
going to convert my physical assets to
digital assets
i'd rather own a digital building than
on a physical building
because if i had a billion dollar
building in moscow who can i rent that
to
but if i have a billion dollar digital
building i can rent it to anybody in any
city in the world
anybody with money and the maintenance
cost is
almost nothing and i can hold it for a
hundred years okay so it's
indestructible building and then finally
i want to move from uh having my assets
in a bank with a counterparty to
self-custody assets
right so and and this is not
it's not just ukraine but this is like
the story in turkey lebanon syria
afghanistan iraq
south america
you don't really want to be sitting with
10 million dollars
in a bank in istanbul the bank's going
to freeze your money
it to lira devalue the lira and then
feed it back to over 17 years right so
self-custody assets would be layer one
bitcoin
self-custody assets it's like
if i if i got my own hardware wallet and
i've either got
uh
[Music]
your your highest form of self-custody
would be bitcoin on your own hardware
wallet or bitcoin in your own
self-custody and the other the other
thing people think about is how do i get
crypto dollars like tether
like some stable coin yeah like i'd
rather if you had a choice would you
rather have your money in a bank in a
war zone in dollars or have your money
in a stable coin on your mobile phone
in dollars
right i mean you take the latter risk
rather than the former war zone
definitely yeah
and you can see that happening like
we've gone from 5 billion in stable
coins to 200 billion yeah in the last 24
months yeah so i do think there's
massive demand
for uh crypto dollars in the form of a
us dollar asset and there's
and everybody in the world would say
yeah i want that
well
unless you're just an extreme patriot
but most people would say i want that
and then a lesser group of people would
say i think i want to be able to carry
my property in the palm of my hand so i
have self-custody of it
you